what would it take to get you to move
across the world to another country
start a business there a german couple
actually set up shop here in las vegas
with their rv rental business and the
pandemic didn't even slow them down as
kirsten joyce reports that's thanks in
part to what we have to offer
tobias frenzel and jessica lichtenberger
are from a small town in southern
germany while the countryside there is
lush and beautiful it's the great
outdoors of the southwestern united
states that truly calls to both of them
i fell in love with the country and
especially with like camping out here
their first rv trip together landed them
in bryce canyon the end of the trip she
was oh let's do like dry camping and
enjoy the nature so she really fell into
it too a business opportunity from
across the globe fell right into their
laps while still living in germany they
bought an rv business out of san
francisco and moved it and themselves to
the heart of las vegas in the beginning
it was hard we're from a very very small
town in germany and then yeah moving
here to this big city yeah it was a big
big step for us but yeah we're glad we
did it and yeah we love it here vegas is
a perfect location and how far ahead do
people book out at these campsites
months probably yellowstone six months
in advance and then you should really
reserve it so as fast as possible really
popular
vacation at the moment they began with
the fleet of five rvs advertising
globally domestically folks who came for
a show or exhibition would book and
travel to a national park then the
pandemic hit international borders and
national parks closed we didn't know
where everything was going and
especially at the beginning when
everything was shut down we didn't see a
light at the end of the tunnel but the
tunnel vision they had quickly cleared
as people who didn't want to fly or stay
in a hotel sought out rvs to rent so in
essence you were able to double your
fleet during the pandemic how since the
first really really good review they
have a lot of returning customers they
to all their friends so yeah let's do it
with them in three years time growth has
been the name of the game expanding
their fleet from five to twelve rvs our
newest one yeah
we love it
and then it sleeps how many oh it sleeps
up to seven wow as a small business it
can be tough to compete with the big
players but they use an advertising
platform called outdoorsy we have
australians we have canadians we have
british people so it's pretty popular in
i would say all over the world it's a
good occasion for us to to marketing our
business a business allowing tobias and
jessica to share their love of
exploration with others from around the
globe it's the most important time of
the year is the vacation
and everything should be perfect
kirstjen joyce live local now